Que le sacrifice commence dans le grand temple du soleil !
Ô, Pachacamac, Puissant Astre du Jour !
Pachacamac ! Mais oui !
A l'époque, on avait découvert une statue
de la divinité Pachacamac sur un site de fouilles,  près de Lima à côté du temple du soleil.
Et Hergé a même imaginé des
couleurs alors que les archéologues viennent tout juste
de montrer que les représentations des divinités étaient peintes et multicolores.
Bonjour,  curieuses et curieux !
Une équipe d'archéologues français et
péruviens s'est intéressée à cette pièce
conservée au musée archéologique de
Pachacamac.
Ce mât en bois gravé de deux mètres 34
est une représentation de
la divinité Pachacamac, considérée par les
incas comme un dieu créateur,  mais aussi
comme le maître des tremblements de terre.
Pachacamac était également un
oracle puissant que les empereurs  incas
venaient consulter dans le sanctuaire du même nom,  situé sur la côte péruvienne non loin de Lima.
La statue a été découverte en 1938, alors qu'on la croyait détruite par les espagnols
depuis 1533,  lors de leur conquête de l'empire Inca.
I'll be back !
Et il se trouve qu'elle comportait en certains endroits des colorations rouges mystérieuses.
Est-ce que c'était du sang,  des restes de pratiques sacrificielles ?
En 2019,  alors que l'origine de ces taches rouges n'était toujours pas élucidé
des chercheurs français présents sur le site de fouilles
avaient dans leurs valises
deux microscopes portables utilisant la
fluorescence des rayons X pour analyser
les pierres du temple peint.
Pour l'anecdote, l'un de ces instruments a été
conçu pour aller sur Mars
ce qui est quand-même vachement la classe.
Ces microscopes permettent de faire des
analyses chimiques non-invasives et non-destructives.
Petit, mais costaud !
Les microscopes sont
alors utilisés pour analyser l'idole en bois.
Et il révèlent que le rouge n'est pas
la seule couleur présente.
On trouve  aussi du jaune par endroits et du blanc
sur les dents d'un personnage.
Les scientifiques déterminent également les
éléments chimiques composant les tâches
et ils découvrent que le rouge n'est pas
du sang,  mais un pigment qui contient du
mercure et du soufre,  c'est à dire du
cinabre : un minerai de mercure utilisé
depuis plus de 2000 ans dans la région .
Même s'il existe différents gisements de cinabre en
Amérique du Sud
ils sont très localisés,  et chacun
possède une signature chimique qui lui est propre.
Mais les premiers travaux d'archéologues américains montrent que le
cinabre utilisé dans les Andes,
avant l'arrivée des espagnols,  provient
presque exclusivement de la mine de
Huancavelica
qui est située à près de 400 km de Pachacamac.
Ce minerai rouge était donc rare et précieux et l'idole a probablement été peinte
avec l'intention de montrer un pouvoir économique et politique.
On va tout repeindre !
Je veux leur en mettre plein la vue !
Je veux du rouge là !
Je vous du rouge là-bas !
Je vous du rouge partout !
Make this temple great again !
Mais ce n'est pas fini !
L'idole a également été datée au carbone 14
pour la première fois et il se trouve
qu'elle a été façonnée près de sept
cents ans avant l'apogée de l'empire Inca
aux alentours de 731 après
jésus-christ et probablement par la civilisation Huari.
Ainsi,  grâce aux
nouvelles technologies,  les archéologues
ont pu confirmer que les incas avaient
bien repris une divinité existant dans
la culture Huari,  bien avant leur arrivée,
et que les couleurs étaient utilisées
pour peindre richement les idoles dans
des cultes antérieurs aux incas
certains d'entre eux préservés dans le temps.
Même si la symbolique de ces couleurs reste encore à découvrir
la polychromie change
notre vision des idoles et des monuments
et elle montre l'importance de la
couleur et du choix des matériaux
utilisés dans les rituels andains avant
l'arrivée des espagnols.
Voilà je sais que vous attendez Inca-
lembour pour terminer cet épisode mais
ne partez pas,  nous avons une grande
annonce !
Ô,  grand Zeste Chacamac !
Ô, Marie !
L'idole a parlé !
Tu reprendras le flambeau de
Zeste de Science.
Gloire à Marie !
Yes !
Voilà, j'ai passé trois belles années -
presque trois ans - à vos côtés et donc
je voulais vous dire merci, merci pour tout,
et même si je pars sur de nouvelles aventures
restez sur Zeste de Science, vous n'allez pas vous ennuyer.
Vous êtes en bonne compagnie.
Marie...
Hé bien,  bonjour à tous,  je suis Marie
et c'est moi qui reprend le flambeau de Léa.
Vous verrez,  on va passer de bons moments ensemble
au travers de nouvelles aventures, remplies de science et d'humour.
Et surtout,  n'oubliez pas de vous abonner !